tu rites et des femmes de la majorité
c'est ainsi que madame simone veil qui
n'avait jamais figuré dans ces sondages
vient en tête devant tous les hommes
devant 55%
madame simone veil dans le grand public
a pu faire largement connaissance lors
du récent débat à l'assemblée nationale
sur l'avortement sera d'ailleurs à
nouveau sur la sellette aujourd'hui
puisque ce projet de loi sur
l'interruption de grossesse revient ce
soir en deuxième lecture devant les
députés
madame veil demeure confiante et elle
nous a dit ce que ce combat car c'en est
un à représenter pour elles
vous avez en quelque sorte d'avocat donc
de cette fois qu'elle était pour vous le
moment le plus difficile jusqu'à présent
sur le plan sur le plan personnel
certain moment des débats parlementaires
ont été difficiles même si je me suis
rendu compte que certains propos étaient
dues à la passion à une passion parfois
justifiées de temps en temps là ça a été
vraiment des moments difficiles mais je
crois que ce qui est très important je
ne sais pas en définitive comment le
texte va se retrouver tout à fait en fin
de parcours
c'est par exemple le vote du sénat que
le sénat est adopté ce texte après les
débats d'une très grande sérénité d'une
très grande dignité et adopter le texte
avec deux tiers des sénateurs je crois
que c'est une chose importante car ça
prouve qu'en définitive il y avait un
consensus général est d'ailleurs
ressorti d'un certain enfin consensus en
tout cas très important qui est ressorti
d'ailleurs 2
de certains sondages ont pu être fait si
c'était à refaire sur y est vous prête
de nouveau à vous battre sans compter
comme vous l'avez fait pour défendre un
texte
oui sûrement sûrement la même de la même
façon peut-être simplement en tirant
parti de certaines certaines leçons qui
vont donner sur la façon d'appréhender
les problèmes on sur certaines attitudes
mais comme je pense que c'était en
définitive la moins mauvaise des
solutions et que sa portée comme je vous
ai dit certains progrès je n'ai pas
changé de point de vue et donc je
referais la même chose passante dans ce
débat et même dans ce combat sans
concession
quelle est la conclusion que vous
retirez pour vous personnellement je ne
tire pas de son personnel je crois avoir
pris les choses simplement comme je les
ressentais et de m d'avoir fait les
choses les unes après les autres d'avoir
franchi les étapes et d'avoir fait
chaque petite chose au mieux comme je
pouvais sans en tirer deux leçons
particulières dont quelles raisons avez
vous accepté ce poste et en particulier
de défendre ce texte est ce que ce ne
sont pas des ambitions j'ai une vie
professionnelle depuis longtemps et
chaque fois que j'ai travaillé quel que
soit ce que j'ai fait que soit
l'administration pénitentiaire ou
ensuite à la direction des affaires
civiles quand j'ai travaillé sur des
textes quand j'ai quelque chose à faire
j'aime que ce soit bien fait selon ce
que je pense surtout c'est ce qui me
paraît le plus le plus important c'est
de mettre mes idées
être ministre c'est une occasion
privilégiée de pouvoir réaliser les
choses qu'on pense mais quand on est un
poste même de magistrats comme je lé
était qu'il travaillait sur des projets
de loi
mon travail c'est est de convaincre les
ministres de mes idées éventuellement je
suis arrivé quelquefois pas toujours et
en tout cas de faire le mieux que je
pouvais ce qui était alors on aura
absents aussi humilité si vous étiez un
jour vous demander de rentrer dans le
rang même dans un avenir proche
accepteriez-vous pour tout à fait tout à
fait y ait un jour un haut magistrat qui
manie si on faisait balayer les rues
vous le feriez bien je crois que les
choses m'intéressent les gens et les
choses m'intéressent alors je crois que
si demain je ne retrouve magistrat ça ne
fera tout à fait tout à fait égal et
j'essaie de le faire comme je pense que
ça doit être fait